careful guys my name is trying to
welcome back to my game into the series
so I'll be completely honest with you
guys with everything that's been going
on lately I'm completely unprepared for
today's video that's okay because gonna
have a nice chill session and we're just
gonna slap in batch rendering into haze
if it's like no big deal because it's
really not um we'll probably not going
to get the whole batch render a
completely done today because that video
probably be like an hour and a half but
how'd you basically want to take our
existing render a 3d API and kind of
move it into more of like a batch
rendering situation side note you can
see that I am not in the new office
because that building is likely getting
shut down because of everything's been
going on so just fantastic really that I
moved everything into that office now
we're back here back home back at the
Cherno home so I hope you guys are all
keeping safe don't do anything stupid
try and limit your time outside don't
underestimate this thing because it
really is kind of a very big deal if you
didn't catch the last episode I did put
up an overview of hazel 20/20 so check
out that video if you haven't already
basically it's just me going through
what our plans are for this yeah I think
it's definitely important to know the
direction in which the project you're
working on is heading
whether that be like something that
you're fully working on or if it's
something that you're kind of
contributing to because if you don't
have a sense of direction it's kind of
difficult to actually you know create a
software project
anyway let's kind of get right into this
not really much that needs to be said by
surrendering something that we've kind
of talked about if you're new to batch
rendering and I'm not gonna be I'm not
gonna try and explain too much with the
code that I'm gonna be writing here
today because I already have there's a
series called batch rendering there's
the first video check it out it's like
four or five episodes or something like
that it'll teach you everything about
batch rendering and how to kind of I
guess bash together 2d quads so that you
can all render them in one draw call
check that out because that's what we're
gonna be putting into hazel today let's
jump in okay so this is the current
state of render a 2d as I mentioned
we're just gonna have a really nice
chill session here this is what we ended
up with last time I think the last time
we actually touched the codebase was to
move across all of the kind of changes
that I had to make to Hazel when I was
writing that game in an hour thing if
you guys haven't seen that video or I
meani game in an hour using hazel check
it
up there because I did actually
practically use hazel to build a game I
was able to realize like what needed to
be added to hazel and then we kind of
added all that stuff and that's what
this is that's why we have this kind of
rotated cord and a normal quarter and
checkerboard and all that stuff so
that's all happening within sandbox 2d
you know all these errors that's just
visual studio and then what I want to do
today and as I mentioned last time we
don't want to touch this API at all
begin scene and scene we've got that
because it's important to kind of create
a context for our rendering scene some
of the words our context the moment is
just simply a camera so since we have a
camera we need to have kind of this
begin scene and same thing and then we
have all of our primitives that we draw
within that so what I want to do is
conveniently use the beginning and
ending of a scene as an attempt to kind
of batch everything together into one
drakul now obviously if you're seeing is
excessively large so for example let's
just throw a number out there above ten
thousand quads then maybe we want to
kind of divide that into multiple drawer
causes and I don't know exactly what the
right number is it's really important to
run some tests on your target platform
on your target hardware because if you
just kind of throw numbers out there
like yeah let's just batch together a
hundred thousand quads into one draw
call like it's difficult to kind of just
set a number like that and I certainly
don't have a number so this is probably
something that we'll play around with
and we'll see what works for now we'll
set it to 10,000 because I think that's
a reasonable number and also we probably
won't be drawing much more than that
anyway so the idea is that when you do
begin scene when you do an scene will
create one kind of batch right so we
will attempt to render everything in one
draw call
however if within that same begin scene
and scene you exceed that limit of
10,000 quads that is simply gonna flush
everything it's got and then start again
start a new batch so in other words
it'll start a new draw call so if you
try and render let's just say 22,000
quads between one begins scene and and
scene that should come out as three draw
calls probably subject to other things
such as textures like if you want to use
a hundred different textures for that
it's probably going to end up being more
more batches so with that being said
let's go to our render a 2d and see what
we actually need to do this is kind of a
struct of all of our data we've
got a quad vertex array because I guess
I wrote this in a little bit of a way
that both ensured that we would probably
get around to batch rendering one day
but also because we kind of used that
quad as our template to render anything
that we need to currently render it's
just that it happens to be a separate
drawer call at the moment so really what
we need to do is change the way that our
vertex buffer gets created at the moment
when we create a vertex buffer you can
see that we immediately push in those
square vertices they kind of go from
negative zero point 5 to positive zero
point 5 so we get a 1 by 1 unit quad or
square so we're gonna delete all of that
because obviously the idea is we're
gonna have a dynamic vertex buffer
instead and then instead of creating a
Vedic buffer like this we really just
need to create a vertex buffer that has
a given size so this is interesting
because I'm not sure that Hazel's API
like the buffer supports that because we
haven't had to deal with that yet
obviously so yeah the only way that we
can create a vertex buffer at the moment
is by passing a pointer to a bunch of
floods and then also a size so we need
to extend that API so that we can
actually just create a vertex buffer
based on a size so we'll just say you in
33 size and we'll kind of make that a
guess is the first first create function
since there's only got one parameter I
like to kind of organize it that way um
since we're here as well we might as
well take a look at index buffers so
yeah I mean the index buffer this stays
exactly the same we don't really care
about that it's important to note that
currently hazel supports as well hazel
only supports 32-bit index buffers this
is important because just in case you
want to render like a 16-bit index
buffer which is probably something we'll
had in the future we need to just kind
of take that into account so I just I
really hope I don't forget that because
I've made that mistake before okay cool
so moving on um let's kind of implement
this and then we we will scare these
Hazel's
let's kind of just copy and paste
I guess this and actually let's move
this up yeah
while I'm tapping this card how are you
guys doing write a comment below let me
know what your what your life is like
nowadays with all the crazy stuff going
on is uh yeah interesting times
okay so we need to grab this and get rid
of that and then we'll just have a sighs
so if that happens right um let's see
this is our kind of creation and I guess
I'll add the profile to it as well
this is our current vertex buffer
creation what we need to do is basically
do the same thing as we do here except
the only differences we possibly null
pointer for our data pointer so we're
just creating this kind of vertex buffer
which has a size but actually no data
and so this last parameter is the hint
that we give to OpenGL as to how we're
going to use the data this is just a
hint meaning that if you give it if I
leave this as static drawer are still
gonna work it's just likely gonna be
slower because I've been gels not gonna
expect us to continue writing data to
that buffer every frame so by changing
into a dynamic drawer we're basically
saying that data is likely to be
entering the buffer or being written to
the buffer every France that's obviously
what we want since we'll be continually
updating that buffer every single frame
okay I think that's about it that's
really all we need to do just make sure
that you don't pass any data make sure
it's dynamic draw and the size remains
the same so now we should have the
ability to kind of create this based on
what we specify the kind of maximum
number of calls to be so again we said
we wanted 10,000 quartz so I'm just
gonna write Const UN 32 T you know max
Watts will set to maybe well 10,000
because that's what we kind of agreed on
so since we want the max pause at 10,000
we'll set the Maps vertices to be mass
both times for bigger scale four
vertices cup water will set the Maps
indices to be match spots times six
because we have six in this instead what
and I think that's probably all we need
now maps meaning and over in Maps here
even though max is
kind of like be size it's just because
if it exceeds this it's gonna have to be
a draw like a neutral call so this is
essentially the maximum amount of
vertices that we can have or the max
amount of indices we can have per a
single draw call so not like the maximum
for the renderer and then it just
explodes it's just a maximum that we can
have for a given draw call okay awesome
so one other thing I'll do is quickly as
a little side thing well I want to do
two things actually just looking at this
card because I'm not sure why I wrote it
this way and maybe I'm just being stupid
right now but I so I call this storage
which I should just call it data because
it is as on the school daughters how
about trading it someone rename this to
render a 2d data maybe I just didn't
like that double D there or something
but anyway riot render a 2d data because
I usually call these things data also
there's really no reason for this to be
like a dynamic allocation here like as
an it just doesn't need to be I think
the only time I like the only reason
that why I may have done that is just to
control the lifetime because you can see
we deleted and shutdown we created here
but honestly with the with the fact that
this does not ever get this data is just
a struct filled with data it does not
get initialized until in it I think that
it's fine just as a little bit of a
cleanup thing to actually just move that
out from being a pointer to just being
like a kind of statically allocated
object here because it's not like again
it's not like if this was doing opengl
stuff then yeah we will probably want to
explicitly in instantiate or initialize
this kind of data within the init
function but in this case we just really
don't need to so for now at least again
may change in the future but for now
we're just gonna get rid of that and
what that means is it will have to
replace all of this with s data dot all
right cool so there we go just a little
bit of housekeeping I guess okay so max
vertices is probably what we're looking
at so this needs to be a size and I
believe this size that it is in bytes so
we need to basically do s data dogmas
vertices times the size of every
so we don't have a vertex definition do
we do we really not like what it had a
we maybe idolater yeah we just use
floats didn't we
okay well in that case we'll make a
struct called water X now the reason I'm
calling everything quad by the way is
because this renderer will eventually
support lines as well and obviously a
line vertex is gonna differ from a quad
vertex and like a line index buffers
getting different from a quarter index
Bufferin and so on and so forth so
that's why I'm explicitly calling this
quad okay so what we want to do here is
basically define everything that little
quad is at the moment we're dealing with
position text coordinate obviously we'll
have to extend that a little bit but for
now we'll kind of keep in that same that
same data because that this is gonna be
like phase one of our renderer is
obviously gonna try and be as simple as
possible so we'll have a position and
we'll have a text award but in the
future obviously you know we'll have
we'll have a color
we'll have a texture ID we might even
have like a mask ID but we'll will
address masks probably in the distant
future and what else it's probably from
now right yeah position color am I
missing anything am I missing anything
important
I don't think so all right we'll keep
that in there for now okay so now we
have our quad vertex and the we're kind
of creating our quad vertex buffer
important obviously that whatever we set
the layout of the vertex buffer kind of
corresponds to this I'm also gonna
probably rename this to just be called
1bb
because instead of square baby because
that's not really true okay indices so
let's take a look at that so what we
want to do is basically generate a whole
bunch of indices now because these these
are likely gonna be large I think I'm
gonna want to actually allocate them on
the heap so what I'll do is I'll create
an array of these will say quad indices
I'm
maybe maybe has something to do without
consonants so that's a joke by the way
so not very good one either so Max
indices is how many indices we obviously
want so how many is that that's like 60
yeah
60,000 you and 32 T's so that's how much
is that like 240 kilobytes I mean that's
still obviously permissible to have on
the stack but in case someone wants to
blow that number up it might actually
close a stack overflow so I'd rather
just dynamically allocated here I
definitely don't want to use it or
anything like that so we'll just kind of
remember I guess to delete these not a
big deal at all okay so we have quad
indices let's kind of push that in here
it's really important in at a lifetime
of this by the way I do a new kind of
the reason this code doesn't look that
great to me is because this is obviously
assuming that these indices this data
gets uploaded to the GPU immediately
because if it doesn't and right and it
hits this if it gets queued or something
like that
it's not gonna ever be uploaded like
you're gonna crash your program because
you've deleted the data you free the
data so it's a little bit dangerous I
understand that which is why it's
definitely better to kind of reference
count everything and maybe that way you
know you hand over a reference to this
which could be running on it like a
different thread like the render thread
and then when it's done with it it
releases and since this is already
released as well you kind of get this
you know this basically this reference
counting system where once the reference
is a zero nothing's holding on to it
then it deletes it so it's kind of like
a shed pointer but anyway we'll do this
for now because we know that we don't
have any threads or any queues or
anything like that everything's done
immediately but that's just a kind of
like a side note just so that you guys
keep that in mind okay sorry this is not
gonna work obviously um so what do we
have we have quad indices and then the
size is gonna be as data max indices
times size of un to 32 now this better
not be the count because I feel like it
is feel like I always do this um so if
we look at index not for Korea eh
anyway you drill down here yeah so you
can see we have count so it's called
count here this is a huge issue
it's called count here but
even here it's called size that is a
massive leap bad thing to do so make
sure that count means count in terms of
elements and the size means size in
terms of bytes because if you can mix
them up you're gonna have a bad day so
now that we know that and yeah I know
the API slightly consistent but the idea
is that we we don't need this this is
not useful information because we know
that the index buffer is a 32-bit
indexed offer right meaning that he uses
like 32-bit integers not 16-bit or
whatever so that's why you know if you
create an index buffer that is not a UN
32 table like it's a UN 16 T or
something then you would also not need
to know the size because you know it's
16 bits so this little kind of thing
even though like part of me is almost
like maybe just leave it in there for
consistency but no I don't want to so
there we go
and then we have yes this this is our
odd index buffer we've created that
we've deleted the oh yeah and obviously
the important part here is that when we
create this index buffer you can see
that we immediately do gel buffer data
we send those indices there and then
obviously that happens before we delete
them so that's the important thing
tonight okay white texture we'll leave
that in there what I'm gonna deal with
textures for now we're just gonna get
these quads being bashed together that's
pretty much it
okay now we need some other things here
obviously to keep track of how many
quads were trying to draw so I'll say
you and 32t will just say index count or
quad index count so we'll initialize
that to zero so every time we draw a
quad we're gonna increment this by 6 so
that we know how many indices indices
have actually have to draw when we flush
everything ok so drop 1 this is the
function that's going to change so which
one should we attack first by the way we
we do need a color for our quads because
I think we're currently drawing a red
one and a blue one so we might as well
just add color in right now otherwise
we're not really going to it's not
really gonna work very well so maybe
let's put this here and we'll call this
color we have position color to do text
ID okay and then we have to obviously
make sure that
drop up a layout hey color alright so
this means that we should be able to
render with colors and obviously we will
have to modify our shader to make that
happen
as well okay so our next step really is
modifying these drawn quad functions
let's just start with one probably not
going to bother with rotation either
rotation for batch rendering isn't
particularly difficult either all you
really have to do is create a rotation
matrix and then multiply every vertex of
your quad with that rotation matrix like
in the CPU side like here and then you
get your rotation being a like bash and
everything because obviously you can't
do that matrix multiplication inside the
shader since it's all gonna be one batch
but then that also brings the I guess
the the other thing that we could do
which is obviously having like a
transformation stack some otherwise you
can push a matrix into the stack
everything will be applied to that
matrix and then you can pop that matrix
and then your quads will no longer be
affected by that matrix and that's also
something that you'd probably implement
in C++
anyway whatever just stuff for the
future this is the big thing there
there's kind of position size color so
let's see what we want to do here so we
basically need to create and push it
through this vertex buffer he like for
new vertices right so to make that
happen we need to actually insert begin
scene we need to actually map the vertex
buffer so you could use geo map buffer
but it's probably a bit better to use
off a sub data for like uploading stuff
so what I'll do is we'll have one vertex
so I'll pull this up here because we
need to use it I love what vertex I call
this so this is our board vertex buffer
base and then pointer
so I'll set both whether these to normal
just initial eyes improperly and then
what will happen is we basically need to
allocate inside probably when we do this
let's mmm-hmm why should I put this
maybe I will put it here um I guess it's
to do with a better stuff but will say
quadratic buffer base equals new quad
vertex and then we do estado max
vertices we have basically enough
storage for the tied vertex buffer right
that's data okay so then what we do is
when it's time to begin scene right we
set the pointer equal to the base so now
we can write into this and we can freely
increment this and obviously we don't
lose track of where the base of our
memory allocation is and then an end
scene this is where we need to actually
do the flushing so I don't think all
right yes applause that either so we'll
have to set that up in a minute but
let's do this first so now that we've
got where's our drop quite a function
that we're actually using I think it's
this one yeah okay so we basically get
the buffer pointer right and then into
here we can write all of our data
because this should be at the position
of the next vertex that we write into so
into here we need to push back the
position and we need to obviously do
this per vertex so for the first vertex
we're going to push back the position
but color the color is going to be the
same for all vertices and then the text
quard
with the given we don't really need it
here but I guess there's no harm in
having it maybe you know it's some math
operations that we can get it get away
with not using because obviously we're
trying to draw a colored like a colored
quad flat color or I'm a tetra quad here
but we'll just set them up anyway so we
can copy them easily later so this is
the bottom left so the texture
coordinate is zero zero
I guess all right these floats the
position is just whatever the position
is because we defined the position from
the bottom left is that right or do do
we want to define the position from the
middle that's also a good question to
ask and I don't know what the answer is
yet we'll see okay
that's always a common kind of question
okay let's copy these four times so we
have the we're going counterclockwise
right so the next one would be the kind
of bottom right so this becomes and this
is a three-component position isn't it
yeah okay so this becomes position node
X plus size X and then just position the
Y and 0 this one over here becomes both
x and y and this one here becomes just Y
so this is the top left and then we
oversee you order these dual semicolons
tetra coordinates so they kind of go
with the variables so in other words if
there's a plus size you add it you
change that quarter to 1 so it's an
easier way to think about that okay
that's it so obviously positive by the
way is like going up going down is
negative in the y axis okay so there we
go that's it so now we've done that we
don't need to worry about you color
anymore the tiling factor is still
important but that's for our textures
anyway so I don't know we'll keep that
in there but you know we really need it
why texture binds this stuff is
meaningless to have here I'm actually
going to comment it out because
obviously when I'm going to be drawing
indexed at all here that's gonna be
happening
like when we flush our Endre at the end
of our batch okay so that's done this is
really the only function is gonna work
at the moment and I'm okay with that
let's ignore all the other one so let's
go to end same because that's what we're
sitting so n sane means that we've
handed out scenes in other words it
should actually do the rendering here
now what I usually do is I write a
function called flush the reason being
that like you know for profiling and for
like other reasons it's usually just
nice to you know
put your card up into different like
different sections I guess that's why we
usually like to use functions that's the
only reason but at the moment we'll have
flush being called from NZ honor D
actually actually the other really
important part is that um I mean M scene
could or could obviously do flush all
the time but we're also going to have to
handle the case of if we've exceeded the
amount of vertices that we can render
and by the way one thing I forgot was to
increment the something when showing up
what do we call it our quad index count
maybe did show up to be plus equal six
okay um and then actually I guess in
begin same probably want to set the quad
index count to zero so we're basically
resetting everything here okay cool so
what is MC I'm gonna do so MC n is going
to actually upload the data to the GPU
so it basically needs to do quad vertex
buffer which we have so what you really
need to retain that I'll add that up
here we have quad vertex array I'll also
add quad vertex buffer so that's what
we'll use instead of creating one here
so this becomes half data oops
s data what about hex buffer there we go
and then that way we can just hopefully
do um a set data or I don't know a copy
data what's the good front what's a good
name for this function I think said dad
is gonna be fine for now I'm not gonna
get too hung up with what to call things
cuz that's a trap so we need to set the
data to basically we need to figure out
what well we want to set a true Corvette
has off a base but the size is gonna be
interesting because the size of this is
going to be and I can call this the data
size that's going to be the
what about the point I'm - clapping bass
but obviously if you do the subtraction
like this it's just going to tell you
the number of elements because these are
quad vertices so you actually have to
cast these two basically something that
is one byte large so I'm going to cast
this to a UN - a - t because of course
is one byte and in that way when we do
the subtraction we actually get how many
elements it takes up in terms of bytes
which is what we want
all right data size is in there that's
it that's all we have to do so it said
that we need to implement that function
obviously it doesn't exist so let's go
to our buffer class and then over here
we'll have a virtual void set data so
this is going to take in
I avoid pointer AB data I guess I can
make it a constant Y pointer and then
it's also going to take in a UNH which
means size and I'll set that equal to 0
of course and we'll copy it for our
OpenGL buffer class we'll paste it so
this was after after get layout set
layout let's move it up it's probably
more important than the layout oh maybe
not
I guess not but doesn't matter I want to
have it up here set up override and then
we'll implement the function okay so set
data what's that gonna do so basically
what we used to do is find the buffer
gel array buffer and the buffer being
and render ID and then we need to kill
buffer sub data okay
so target obviously is array buffer the
offset is 0 so we don't provide an
offset at the moment I don't think
that's strictly well it might be nice to
have because this is obviously the
target buffer offset but since we don't
have a use case for it yeah I'm not
gonna add it at the moment
sides are going to be size and
daughter's gonna be data so it's pretty
simple stuff all right and I think that
is it
so once we've set the data we're happy
to flush now so what we need to do is
basically just execute the draw call so
the same way that we do render a draw
indexed or the same way that we did it
here rehna command it was called
Brenda command draw indexed we basically
just draw out their tax rate so a
start-up vertex right now this is
probably going to be a trap
because quadratics right because
obviously this doesn't take in the index
count which is not good so what does
this actually do um draw index just to
sit in the right function OpenGL
renderer API draw in next text in the
vertex very well so much indirection yes
this doesn't and sign it and it
obviously draws it draws the entire
index buffer which is not gonna work for
us
and if yeah so what we really want to do
is probably extend this slightly and we
can do it pretty easily
we just need to actually find the right
file here what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to literally at a UN 32 D
count or rather index count and we'll
set that to 0 by default so in other
words what we're doing is basically
saying that if it's well what we're
gonna ride is some code that says that
if it's 0 then we're going to just use
the vertex arrays like the full index
count but if we specify an index count
as other than 0 then obviously that's
how many we want so we'll have our index
count here so basically what I mean is
my 32 G in count will say it's gonna be
if index count is 0 right or if it's not
0 maybe we can just write code like this
to keep it a bit cleaner and we can use
the next off account otherwise we use
the next count so that way we can
actually tell so if the counts been set
then we use the count and then that
makes it nice and simple so that means
that we can now just simply write s dot
a-- what index count and we should be
good so i think i think that that's good
and I might have to extend it here as
well unfortunately
[Music]
because yeah whatever because of the way
that this is written um okay
there we go that's compiler code um I
don't know if this is gonna work
they're probably mixed up amidst a bunch
of stuff so position color and text cord
is what it looks like let's take a look
at our shader because that's probably
going to need modification so what rate
are we actually using texture that GLSL
is the shader so let's kind of extend
this let's add a color this will be a
vent for will keep a text cord there we
need to send the color so we have a
transform that's not gonna exist anymore
so we'll get rid of that we'll have an
ounce
Veck for the color and that will
obviously be a color we'll make sure
that we take that in as well color and
then what we'll do is at the moment
we're not supporting textures I'll
comment that out we'll say color equals
V color basically so you specify color
and that's it and that should work I
think pretty well for us so we'll ignore
everything else because obviously next
time we're gonna just we want to rewrite
the whole thing but for now we should
get something on the screen hopefully is
that all we is that really all we need
so that was simple so let's go into
sandbox tui and so we'll do begin scene
we went for anything rotated we went for
anything with a texture let's throw this
same quarter but just not rotated so
we'll just do it draw quad we'll get rid
of the rotation just when we get to
different colors and we do end scene
which does the upload and then does the
flush which actually draws everything on
an urn let's just hit f5 and see what
happens honestly all right as you can
see we get nothing on screen and that's
exciting sir apparently that did not
work as well as I intended so that's the
diagnosis and see what went wrong I'm
just gonna check this stuff really
quickly just for sanity's
sake so we have all of our indices here
oh we didn't generate any indices wow I
just forgot about that
so what are we setting our agencies to
an empty array beautiful let's go
through this and actually set them
properly sorry
how many indices do we want we want we
want maps indices that will say as Dada
max indices and then we'll implement
this by six and then we'll just set them
up here so we'll have an offset and then
we'll just say what indices quad indices
I plus zero equals so we have our offset
plus zero here so the idea is one six of
these so 0 1 2 2 3 0 and then we
increment our offset by 4 just so that
we the next ones are gonna be like you
know four five six six seven four and
then obviously here we just write
straight into one two three four five
okay that should be good and that should
go all the way up to max indices these
obviously need to be divisible by six
because and they will be because there's
time six here so we're obviously relying
on that but I think that's safe okay and
then we upload the right data so let's
let's see if that makes a difference
that might make it work awesome
there we go so our camera still works
everything still works but these two are
now drawn in a single draw call or at
least they should be drawn in a single
draw call so that is now the beginning
of that rendering in hazel so what we'll
do next time is basically extend this
API so that we can also draw textures
and deal with like our tiling or
whatever else we had there in our
default shader we'll have to kind of
rewrite our shader and make sure that it
works with that and we'll also test out
that probably test out that 10000 quad
limit and we also need to write some
code that obviously will if it exceeds
10,000 will flush the existing kind of
batch I guess and then start a new batch
with the rest of everything and I think
it's gonna take a little bit of time to
get textures to work properly
just because yeah we have to make sure
handle Texas laws correctly we handle up
to 32 textures we need to have that base
white texture and we need to extend the
vertex attributes and everything to
actually have a texture ID anyway hope
you guys enjoyed this video
I'm glad to be back I'm doing a few
things new this month it's a first of
all patron accomplice aperture knows the
best way to help support this series and
especially in time like this like I
really appreciate you guys I really
appreciate your support I'm gonna try
and be as productive and as optimistic
as possible during this time and try and
deliver as much content as possible and
part of that is tomorrow what I'm doing
is for patrons I'm starting live
streaming so I'll be live-streaming
myself working on the development branch
of hazel so all the 3d fun stuff live
for like I expect it will be like a two
to three hour stream tomorrow and I'm
gonna try and do that at least once a
week and depending on how much you guys
like it how successful it is I'm gonna
try and basically just stream myself
during the day working on whatever it is
unboxing on so that's it Tony new that
I'm doing I'm super excited I think
it'll probably make me a lot more
productive and hopefully it'll make kind
of I guess you guys more involved with
what I'm doing because I'll be able to
interact with the stream and the streams
are gonna stay online so that you can
watch them later if you miss them more
it's like that so patient office
esthetician are huge thank you to all of
you for watching all of my meet all of
my videos and I will see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]